How do you go from a place where your
poor just kind of spinning as the music
is playing to one in which they're
actually spinning with the music,
hitting the accents, making sure the
audience knows that you're trying to hit
the beats of that music? Well, we're
going to cover that in this video.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Drex here from Drexfactor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video, I'm going to
take you through five different
exercises that will help you be able to
catch the beat of whatever music you're
listening to and make sure that it
reflects in your spinning and flow. But
before we dive in, I just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire
Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroer,
Light Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to
make the videos on this channel
possible. You can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
that they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I have down in the
description of this here video. Okay, so
this is a problem that has multiple
stages of solutions to it. First and
foremost, we need to get used to being
able to actually hear the beat in the
music that we're listening to. And then
we need to start training ourselves to
be able to spin the po in time with it.
And this is actually a deceptively
difficult thing to get down. So what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take you
through not just how to identify the
beat of the music, but also I'm going to
take you through five specific exercises
so that you can begin to learn how to
channel that beat through your poi with
five different types of tricks and ways
of spinning the poi. We're going to
start off with the most basic part of
all which is learning to count to the
music. So in broadest strokes, western
music is usually made up of four beats
that are grouped together into something
called a measure. And every four
measures, something tends to change
about the music, whether it be the
dynamics, the feel of it, what have you.
This can be where we shift from a verse
to a chorus. But the first and most
important task is to be able to hear
that beat and be able to cue into it. If
you can't do that much, you're not going
to be able to synchronize the po to it.
So what I find is really helpful is to
actually just isolate the beat. One
exercise you can do is to actually pull
up a metronome and just practice being
able to snap your fingers in time to it.
You can start by just snapping your
fingers at the beginning of every
measure. Then you can work to snap your
fingers every other beat and then
finally to snap your fingers on every
beat. Here's what it sounds like.
So with the metronome, we're getting a
slightly different sound on the one if
you listen.
So, if I want to snap my fingers on the
one, it'll sound like this. One,
one,
one. Now, every other beat. 1
1 1.
Every beat. 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2
3 4 Personally,
I find it's much more comfortable to
snap on the one and the three and to
move my hand back and forth. This is
actually going to set us up for the next
exercise that we're going to do here.
So, I recommend just getting comfortable
with this, going back and forth,
thinking 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3
4. This alone can take a lot of
practice, so be patient with yourself
and work at it. You want to be able to
queue in and be able to anticipate each
and every beat as it's coming up. All
right. So once you get pretty
comfortable with being able to identify
the beat and snap your fingers back and
forth to it, we can actually take that
knowledge and use it directly with the
poi. In the same way that we move our
hand back and forth as we're snapping
our fingers, we can move our hand back
and forth with the poi in a pendulum as
well. Let me show you. When we start up
here, I can think that I would do the
same thing when I was snapping. Thinking
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4. And with the poi, I go
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 Going
straight back and forth like so. In time
with that metronome.
Awesome. It does need to be said that if
you're going to do this pendulum
exercise, you're probably going to have
to push your pendulums back and forth as
you're going here. If you just do a
straight pendulum with your hand barely
moving, you may or may not synchronize
the PO with the beat. You really have to
emphasize the motion of your hand as you
go back and forth in order to snap the
poi between these two locations in time
with the metronome.
Okay. So, for our next exercise in
honing in our PO spinning to the beat of
the music, we're going to go ahead and
bring in the butterfly. The butterfly is
really, really useful because when we
think about music, we think about there
being something called the downbeat,
which is usually what happens on the one
and the three count in the music, and an
upbeat, which happens on the two and the
four. So, I can think that I'm going to
try and speed up my butterfly to hit
every single beat of the music, 1 2 3 4.
Or I can switch back and forth between
having the down beat of the poi which go
underneath my hands on the one and the
three and the upbeat that is when they
go over my hands on the two and the
four. So I can think 1 2 3 4 like so.
Let's go ahead and try that with the
metronome and see how it goes.
Here we go. So, 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
1 2 3 4 Speed it up. 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 4. Go back and forth between
those two extremes and it will teach you
a lot about how to slow down and speed
up the poi to cue into the beat of the
music. So, you might be asking yourself,
if we're playing around with music that
breaks down into four beat groupings,
how exactly do we use po tricks that
have beats that don't match up with
four? Stuff that isn't two or four
beats. Stuff that is, say, things like
the three beat weave where we have each
hand doing an over, under, back, over,
under, back. Well, the key here is to
hone in on parts of the trick where you
actually do break down into groups of
either two or four. Namely, as we're
doing a three beat weave, we're
switching which hand is on top each
time. And we can shoot to have the
contact point where the hands come back
together as coinciding with the beat of
the music. So, I can think that I'm
going to open up one, come back on two,
open up three, come back on four, and
try to synchronize my three beat weaves
here. In order to do this, whichever
hand is switching around to being on
top, you have to exaggerate the movement
just a little bit in order to make sure
that it lands in the proper way. So once
again, let's do this with the metronome.
Here we go.
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 See, you
can hit the percussion just as well with
a three beat weave. You just have to
know what to look for. Now, by far my
favorite poi trick for working with
music is the poi stall. There's just
something about bringing the poi to a
complete stop and then switching
direction on it that looks to me the way
a drum beat actually sounds. And
luckily, po stalls are a great way to
practice queuing into the beat of the
music. I like to think of this as
happening in kind of a slow fashion. You
want to basically choke up on your
tethers so that your po are about half
length and think that you're going to
try and hit a stall on every one of a
measure. So I would think that I'd be
hitting 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
and doing really exaggerated circles in
between each of the stalls. So let's do
that with our metronome, shall we?
Here we go.
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 The
trick here is getting to make sure that
you're getting enough space in between
each of those stalls so they really
really hit. So for our final PO trick to
synchronize up the music, we're going to
play around with four pedal anti-pin
flowers. And at first, this might seem
like a relatively simple proposition.
After all, there are four pedals and
four beats. Therefore, we're just going
to hit a pedal with each beat, right?
Well, you'd be correct. But there's a
surprisingly difficult challenge hidden
inside of this. Some of you may already
be familiar with the fact that there are
only three down beats in a four pedal
anti-pin flower. That is three points at
which the poi pass underneath the hand.
Left, bottom, right, left, bottom,
right. There is no downbeat associated
with that top pedal. It's just an
upbeat. So, it might seem like the way
to go then is to count off each of those
down beats and the upbeat. In which
case, we'd wind up with down, down,
down, up, and 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4. Problem
is on the sides, we're counting moments
at which the PO is pointing down. And
visually, we really want to have the PO
pointing out to coincide with the beat.
So, how do we get there? What I tend to
do is when I'm on the sides, I think
that I'm looking for each of those
pedals to be something like a stall that
I'm trying to hit on time with the beat.
When it comes to the top and bottom
pedals, I just treat it like I did with
the butterfly, thinking that we're
looking for moments of least and most
effort going up, down, up, down. So al
together we want to think that we're
going to go down side up side down stall
up stall as we go around to make each of
those pedals line up with the beat. So
let's see it in action.
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 There
you go.
All right. So, all this is fine and
dandy when you're practicing with a
metronome, but what about when it comes
to spinning to actual music? What about
when there's all those other instruments
in the mix and the beat might be more
complex than just simply 1 2 3 4? Well,
the long and short of it is is that
you're going to have to practice hearing
that beat in the music, no matter what
else is going on in it. Generally
speaking, you can zero in on that by
listening for a couple specific sounds
in the music. There are two specific
parts of a drum kit that will tell you
where each of these beats are. There's
one that sounds very, very low that's
called either a bass or a kick drum that
sounds like this.
And there's also a higher, more snappy
one that cuts through the mix that
usually is on the two and the four
called a snare that sounds like this.
And of course, there are plenty of
variations on these. And as you listen
to music, you'll find that there's a lot
of different tonal variations on
different kicks and snares in different
songs. But by and large, this is what
you should be listening for and seeing
if you can pull it out of the mix. All
right. Now, let's work with an actual
piece of music and apply all the
knowledge that we've picked up in this
video. We'll go ahead and identify the
beat of the music and be able to count
along to it, as well as go through all
five of the individual PO trick
exercises that I've outlined earlier.
I've gone ahead and pulled a piece of
music out of the YouTube audio library
to use for demonstration purposes. It's
pretty close to 120 beats per minute, so
it won't be that big an adjustment from
what we're used to. If you want to do
this exercise yourself, I will go ahead
and include a link to this piece of
music down in the description, or you
can just do a Google search for popular
songs that are at 120 beats per minute.
There are absolutely no shortage of them
out there. But for right now, let's use
this. And I will show you how we do all
of this.
First and foremost, we got to find the
beat.
[music]
I can already kind of tell where it is,
but I'm still going to wait for the
percussion to uh kick in.
There we go. [music] You hear that?
That's our snare drum. That's our two
and our four. So we can count around
that. [music]
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 and 1 2 3 4 [music] 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 [music] 1 2 3 4 1 2
3 4 Now with butterflies.
1 2 3 4. We have 1 2 [music] 3 4 1 2 3 4
and 1 2 3 [music] 4 1 2 3 4 and three
beat we use now. Wait for the beat to
kick back in here.
1 [music] 2 3 4. Here we go. 2 3 4 1 2 3
[music] 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 [music] 4 And
now our stalls, which we're definitely
going to need to hear the uh uh hear the
beat for. [music]
[music] 3 4 1 2 3 4 [music] 1 2 3 4 1 2
3 [music] 4 Now our four pedal anti-
spin flowers. 1 2 3 4 [music] 1 2 3 4 1
2 3 4 There you go, friends. Awesome. I
hope these exercises were helpful and
more than anything else, I hope that
they have provided a great entryway into
making your poi more musical by honing
into that beat. Did you get anything out
of this video? Please make sure to like,
comment, share, and subscribe to help
other people find it and of course to
help my channel grow.
[music]
This video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I want to give a shout out
to my FL patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you all so much
for supporting my channel, my work, and
my mission. And if you out there want to
get your name in the credits or access
to a whole host of other awesome
rewards, you can do that by checking out
my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo.
I'll [music] leave a link down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
Please check that out and help me out in
my mission of bringing po spinning and
flow arts to the whole wide world. Thank
you in advance. And if you'd like to go
a little bit deeper in making those
stalls musical, I did an entire video
with an exercise on how to get your
stalls to work with the music in any
timing and direction mode. I'll go ahead
and link to that up on screen as well as
down in the description. [music] Thanks
so much for watching. Make sure to get
out and flow yourself today and I'll see
you with a new video real soon. Take
care now. Peace.